europa vuelve a ser el epicentro de la
pandemia por ello varios países intentan
blindarse contra la reciente ola de kobe
19 con nuevas restricciones en grecia
este sábado se formaron largas filas a
las puertas de los comercios y
establecimientos de ocio que ahora
exigen una prueba negativa de
coronavirus para los no vacunados
también obligatoria para los
trabajadores no vacunados de todos los
sectores de apoyo las nuevas medidas
serán eficaces siempre que se apliquen
correctamente y por todos creo que
también han llegado tarde deberían haber
aplicado estas medidas en muchos años en
economía la economía va a sufrir pase lo
que pase y estas medidas eran necesarias
junto a otras así que estoy de acuerdo
con ellas
austria impuso una de las normativas más
estrictas a partir del lunes sólo las
personas inoculadas podrán acceder a
restaurantes hoteles peluquerías y
eventos con capacidad de más de 25
personas por desgracia las cifras
aumentan rápidamente no cabe duda de que
la situación es grave en austria así
como en otros países europeos
en alemania el gobierno en funciones
quiere generalizar la tercera dosis de
la vacuna ante la fuerte incidencia de
los contados que superaron los 34 mil
positivos en las últimas 24 horas
los refuerzos después de seis meses
deben convertirse en la norma no en la
excepción foundation nos esperan semanas
muy difíciles como demuestran las cifras
de contagios diarios en sección sound
rusia por su parte volvió a registrar
cifras diarias similares al inicio de la
pandemia con más de 41 mil contagios
diarios pese a los esfuerzos
gubernamentales por frenar la cuarta ola